sabemos que las cargas eléctricas crean
campos eléctricos y sabemos que la
definición del campo eléctrico es la
fuerza sobre la carga cual carga pues
digamos que cualquier carga que se
encuentre en esta región si tomamos la
fuerza sobre esta carga que llamaremos
q2 aquí está a miku 2 tomamos la fuerza
que actúa sobre mi carga q2 y la
dividimos entre esta carga q 2 y
obtendremos el campo eléctrico en este
punto en el espacio sería bueno tener
una fórmula que nos dijera cuál es el
campo eléctrico en este punto del
espacio sin tener que referirnos a q2
sería útil tener una fórmula que nos
dijera cuál es el campo eléctrico en
este punto del espacio creado por esta
carga q1 aquí en este punto del espacio
sin tener que referirnos a q2
existe tal fórmula si así es y no es
difícil de encontrar aquí quiero hacer
notar que la fórmula que vamos a
encontrar va a ser para la magnitud del
campo eléctrico así que voy a quitar
estas flechas que me indican los
vectores todo esto será para la magnitud
del campo eléctrico y en un momento les
explicaré por qué así que aquí vamos a
encontrar la fórmula para la magnitud
del campo eléctrico en cierto punto y
esto lo vamos a hacer simplemente
insertando la fórmula que conocemos para
la fuerza eléctrica la ley de coulomb
nos da la fuerza entre dos cargas y esto
lo vamos a escribir aquí la ley de
coulomb nos dice que la fuerza eléctrica
entre dos cargas va a ser igual acá la
constante eléctrica que siempre es 9 por
10 a la 9 x 1 que es la primera carga
que está interactuando aquí que sería
esta q no de aquí multiplicada por la
segunda carga
escudos la otra carga que está
interactuando todo esto dividido entre
el cuadrado de la distancia de centro a
centro de estas cargas y como aquí
estamos definiendo el campo eléctrico
vamos a dividir todo esto entre q 2
noten que estas q 2 se cancelan y nos
queda que la magnitud del campo
eléctrico va a ser igual a cara nuestra
constante eléctrica que voy a escribir
aquí abajo para que tengamos presente su
valor k es igual a 9 por 10 a la 9 y
tiene unas unidades extrañas pero sólo
asegúrense de que estas unidades se
operen bien cuando hagan la
multiplicación esto multiplicado por q 1
dividido entre el cuadrado de la
distancia centro al centro de estas
cargas y me pueden decir bueno la otra
carga la cancelamos ya no está así que
me pueden decir bueno la distancia entre
cuales dos cargas bueno esto puede ser
la distancia hacia cualquier punto en el
espacio pueden imaginarse su carga de
prueba
en lugar del espacio la puedo colocar en
cualquier lugar que yo quiera la r será
la distancia a partir de mi carga q1
hacia cualquier punto en el espacio en
el que yo quiera conocer su campo
eléctrico y como esta q2 siempre se
cancela pues no necesitamos incluirla
para nada simplemente podemos encontrar
el campo eléctrico generado a partir de
q 1 hasta cualquier punto en el espacio
r es la distancia tomada desde el centro
de la carga que está creando el campo
eléctrico hasta el punto en el espacio
en donde queremos determinar el campo
eléctrico y así encontramos la fórmula
de la magnitud del campo eléctrico
creado por mi carga q no técnicamente
esto solo se cumple si tenemos una carga
puntual es decir que es una carga
realmente pequeña comparada con las
otras dimensiones del problema o si esto
es simétricamente esférico no importa
siempre que nos encontremos afuera de
esta carga y nuestra carga tenga una
distribución simétrica esfera
homogénea es decir que no toda la carga
esté amontonada en una parte de esta
esfera y tenga una distribución pareja
entonces también podemos usar esta
fórmula siempre y cuando estemos afuera
de esta esfera
esta fórmula nos dice que la magnitud
del valor del campo eléctrico en un
punto del espacio es igual a la
constante eléctrica k
multiplicada por q que es la carga que
está creando este campo eléctrico esto
es importante porque q no es la carga
que está creando este campo eléctrico
aquí ponemos la distancia desde la carga
hasta el punto en donde queremos
encontrar el campo eléctrico y la
elevamos al cuadrado y así obtenemos la
magnitud del campo eléctrico creado por
q en cualquier punto del espacio y por
qué hacemos tanto énfasis en decir que
esto es la magnitud bueno imaginen que
aquí ponemos que esta carga es positiva
ya que la carga que está creando este
campo eléctrico es positiva lo que nos
daría 1
por positivo para nuestro campo
eléctrico y ustedes pudieran pensar que
al ser positiva entonces iría a la
derecha y en este caso funciona coincide
con la dirección real pero digamos que
quieren encontrar el campo eléctrico que
se encuentra en este punto usan su canal
que es un número positivo usan su q que
también es un número positivo porque es
una carga positiva r va a ser un número
positivo porque incluso aunque llegará a
ser negativo que nunca lo va a hacer se
está elevando al cuadrado así que aquí
siempre va a haber un número positivo
así que el resultado total va a ser
positivo y ustedes podrían pensar que a
bueno pues este campo eléctrico va a ir
hacia la derecha pero no esta fórmula no
nos va a dar la dirección hacia donde
apunta el campo eléctrico si ustedes
quisieran incluir el signo positivo o
negativo de la carga aquí si fuera
positivo todo lo que indicaría es que el
campo eléctrico se está generando
radialmente hacia afuera de la carga
radialmente hacia afuera puede ser hacia
la izquierda hacia arriba hacia la
derecha o hacia abajo y todos estos
contarían como positivos al menos en
esta fórmula y es por eso que hacemos
énfasis en que con esta fórmula solo van
a encontrar la magnitud del campo
eléctrico si quieren encontrar la
dirección solo tienen que recordar que
las cargas positivas generan su campo
eléctrico radialmente hacia afuera de
ellas pero aunque esta fórmula solamente
nos da la magnitud esto es realmente
útil así que al usar esta fórmula vamos
a obtener la magnitud del campo
eléctrico generado por esta carga en
cualquier punto del espacio alrededor de
esta carga
resolvamos algunos ejemplos usando esta
fórmula aquí tenemos una carga de dos
nano culos positivos y queremos
encontrar el tamaño y dirección del
campo eléctrico generado por esta carga
tres metros por debajo de ella así que
queremos conocer el tamaño y dirección
del campo eléctrico justo aquí para
obtener el tamaño vamos a usar la
fórmula que acabamos de encontrar que
nos dice que la magnitud del campo
eléctrico creado por una carga q va a
ser igual a cada x esta misma q dividido
entre la distancia que va desde el
centro de nuestra carga hacia el punto
de interés y la elevamos al cuadrado
sustituimos nuestra k que es 9 por 10 a
la 9 y esto lo multiplicamos por nuestra
carga que es 2 na no culpamos positivos
na no es igual a 10 a la menos 9 así que
es 2 por 10 a la menos 9 cool oms y lo
dividimos entre el cuadrado de la
distancia de nuestra carga hasta nuestro
punto de interés
que en este caso son tres metros nunca
olviden elevarlo al cuadrado muchas
veces a las personas se les olvida
elevar este dato al cuadrado y si se les
olvida pues el resultado no va a ser el
correcto así que nunca se les olvide
elevarlo al cuadrado este 10 a la 9 se
va con este 10 a la menos 9 lo que está
bien y 9 dividido entre 3 al cuadrado es
9 dividido entre 9 por lo que también se
cancela y la magnitud del campo
eléctrico nos va a quedar que es de 2
newtons colom
en este punto de aquí esta es la
magnitud del campo eléctrico así
encontramos el tamaño de este campo
eléctrico y para encontrar la dirección
nos preguntamos qué tipo de carga creó
este campo eléctrico es positiva o
negativa las cargas positivas siempre
crean campos eléctricos que están
radialmente hacia afuera de ellas y en
este punto radialmente hacia afuera va a
ser hacia abajo
un campo eléctrico creado por esta carga
de dos nano culos positivos que va hacia
abajo y tiene un valor de dos newtons
por q lo que significa este número
significa que si pusiéramos otra carga
en este punto en el espacio otra carga
pequeña q tendríamos dos newtons por
cada coma que tuviera esta carga ya que
sabemos que el campo eléctrico es la
cantidad de fuerza sobre la carga y vean
que aunque esta cantidad del campo
eléctrico resultó ser positiva la
dirección de este campo eléctrico es
hacia abajo ya que con la fórmula
solamente obtuvimos la magnitud de este
campo eléctrico resolvamos otro problema
más
ahora tenemos una carga de menos 4 micro
cool oms y queremos encontrar el tamaño
y dirección del campo eléctrico en un
punto que se encuentra 6 metros a la
izquierda de la carga usamos la misma
fórmula y decimos que el campo eléctrico
creado por esta carga negativa es
acan que siempre es 9 por 10 a la 9
multiplicada por la carga que está
creando este campo eléctrico que en este
caso es de menos 4 micro cool oms pero
no voy a incluir este signo negativo
porque yo sé que esta fórmula sólo me va
a dar la magnitud del campo eléctrico y
no quiero confundirme poniendo el signo
de esta carga y que piense yo que me
indica la dirección del campo eléctrico
es decir bueno si nos dice la dirección
pero nos dice que todo el campo
eléctrico va a estar radialmente hacia
adentro de esta carga pero es más seguro
créanme es más seguro no poner signos
cuando escribimos la carga aquí y
recuerden que esto nos da solamente la
magnitud del campo eléctrico así que
aquí sólo escribimos 4 micro cool oms
micro es por 10 a la menos 6
y lo dividimos entre la distancia del
centro de la carga hasta este punto que
son nuestros 6 metros así que lo ponemos
6 metros y no hay que olvidar que
tenemos que elevarlo al cuadrado así que
el campo eléctrico nos va a quedar
bueno aquí tenemos 6 al cuadrado es 36 y
9 entre 36 es un cuarto y un cuarto de 4
es 1 por lo que solo nos queda este 10 a
la 9 por 10 a la menos 6 que es 10 a la
3 que es 1000 así que la magnitud de
nuestro campo eléctrico va a ser de 1000
newtons cullum en este punto en el
espacio esta es la magnitud del campo
eléctrico o en otras palabras es el
tamaño del campo eléctrico en este punto
de acá y cómo vamos a encontrar la
dirección de este campo eléctrico
pensemos en ello aquí no incluimos el
signo no porque la dirección no fuera
importante de hecho no lo incluimos
porque la dirección es tan importante
que tenemos
es que calcularla o encontrarla por
separado aquí tengo una carga negativa y
yo sé que las cargas negativas crean un
campo eléctrico que va radialmente hacia
el centro de esta carga por lo que en
este punto el campo eléctrico va a estar
apuntando radialmente hacia el centro de
la carga que es esta dirección
directamente hacia la derecha así que
tenemos un campo eléctrico de mil tons
colom que apunta a la derecha noten que
si yo distraídamente hubiera dejado este
signo acá hubiera obtenido un valor
negativo para el campo eléctrico y al
ver este signo negativo pues quizás yo
piense que quiere decir que va siempre
hacia la izquierda lo que me hubiera
dado la dirección incorrecta y es por
eso que no hacemos esto si ustedes
quisieran incluir el signo aquí lo único
que representa es la dirección del campo
eléctrico generado radialmente hacia
adentro
esta carga negativa pero radialmente
podría ser hacia la derecha si estamos
midiendo este punto de aquí podría ser
hacia la izquierda si estamos midiendo
de acá pudiera ser hacia arriba si
medimos por debajo de la carga o hacia
abajo si medimos por encima de la carga
así que realmente no significa nada por
lo que es más sano dejarlo afuera no
incluir ningún signo negativo aquí y
recordar que esta fórmula sólo nos sirve
para obtener la magnitud del campo
eléctrico y ya que encontramos esta
magnitud podemos encontrar la dirección
fijándonos en el tipo de carga que está
creando este campo y esto nos va a decir
hacia dónde apunta el campo eléctrico en
resumen esta es la fórmula para
encontrar la magnitud del campo
eléctrico generado por esta carga q y
nos dice que la magnitud del campo
eléctrico va a ser igual a k la
constante eléctrica multiplicada por la
carga que está creando este campo
eléctrico dividida entre el cuadrado
estancia que va desde el centro de la
carga hasta el punto en donde queremos
medir el campo eléctrico